the movie opens with some secret
government agents led by Sergeant George
who seem to be on some sort of mutant
hunting Mission they arrive in an
organization building where they
approach a man named Joseph who works
there as a janitor turns out Joseph is
one of the Genetically Enhanced human
beings who possesses supernatural
abilities George introduces himself and
claims to be aware of Joseph's true
identity he asks him to accompany them
but the latter asserts that he hasn't
done anything wrong when the agents
refuse to listen to his plea Joseph
throws his Mop at them and runs away
from the scene the agents chase him down
and eventually Corner him inside a
storage unit they take out their
Advanced weapons to apprehend him but
Joseph uses his powers to LEAP out to
the roof to escape however his efforts
prove futile as there are sniper agents
and a drone in position to track him
down subsequently the agents subdue him
with an advanced taser administer a
sedative and take him back to their
clandestine facility called cisa later
at cisa headquarters George is
approached by Captain Williams who tells
him that these enhanced humans are very
dangerous as they're capable of
arbitrary killings when George informs
that Joseph only tried to run the
captain asserts that some of them are
deceitful and advises him to be careful
William also mentions an elusive
enhanced guy who has been killing his
own kind but they have no lead on him in
the next scene we are introduced to
another enhanced human Anna who is seen
working in a car garage the owner of the
garage Dany is a kind gentleman who has
been trying to get a fake passport for
Anna so that she can escape to China One
day they're visited by a local gangster
named Marco and his men with whom Dany
has been dealing to get the fake
documents however things take a wrong
turn as Marco demands for more money
when Dany refuses to comply Marco orders
his men to beat him up this enrages Anna
who then uses her superpowers to take
down all the gangsters in no time amidst
the chaos Danny is fatally shot
prompting Anna to call 911 for help
following this she grabs her fake
passport and flees the scene George and
his team intercept the emergency call
and begin tracking her down using their
Advanced watch-like device Anna Cycles
back to her minivan in which she has
been staying as she prepares to leave
she is approached by a stranger who
claims that he is here to help her
however she doesn't believe him and
pushes him down with her power before
driving off unbeknownst to her she is
being pursued by the government agents
in another vehicle after driving for a
while Anna finally senses the pursuit so
she immediately changes her way driving
through a narrow path despite this the
agents keep tracking her with their
drone suddenly there is a burst of
energy that shuts off all their tracking
devices including Anna's truck the
agents react quickly and Rush towards
her last known location they soon
surround her van and Order her to
surrender herself Anna steps out and
kneels down on the ground just like
Joseph she also tries to to prove her
innocence claiming that she hasn't
harmed anybody but the agents don't
listen they start electrocuting her with
their taser gun which disturbs her
greatly this raises her anger so she
throws all of them away with a force
field Anna then makes her way inside an
abandoned Barn followed by George
choosing the right moment she ambushes
him and a physical altercation ensues
between the two George uses a flash
grenade to block her vision and then
tasers her again but as he is about to
inject her with a sedative another
enhanced human David shows up from
behind and knocks him down in the next
scene David drives the two into a secure
place where he ties George to a chair he
then wakes him up and presses him to
divulge the whereabouts of other
captured enhanced people when the
sergeant refuses to provide any
information David prepares to kill him
just before the situation escalates Anna
intervenes asserting that arbitrary
killings are unjustifiable David listens
to her and gives George until morning to
divulge the information information he
then walks away leaving the two alone
following this Anna asks for the reason
why George was hunting her down to which
he replies that the enhanced people are
harmful he also tells her that he has
read her file exposing her history of
killing numerous people including her
parents and her therapist at this point
Anna discloses the truth she was taken
away from her parents at the age of four
and doesn't even know who they are after
that she was adopted by a government
organization called cisa that experiment
mented on her and trained her to be a
killer they threatened to kill her if
she didn't comply with their orders she
further reveals the reason why her
therapist died the therapist gave her a
name instead of calling her by her
assigned number so the higher-ups
executed her for humanizing her upon
hearing all of this George realizes that
he hasn't been told the full truth about
the program he's working for the
following morning David in his
monitoring room detects approaching
government agents as a result he sets
out to confront them alone soon after a
fierce fight ensues between the two
parties amidst the struggle the agents
managed to tase him and administer him
with the sedative but David remains
unaffected he takes down all the agents
except for an officer named Scott who
manages to escape back to headquarters
meanwhile George tries to convince Anna
that David might be dangerous suspecting
him to be the one who is killing his own
kind their discussion is suddenly
interrupted by Joseph who is now in
possession of a red blinking device on
his neck he breaks into the house and
starts attacking Anna while the two
fight George manages to untie himself
and then injects Joseph with a sedative
the sergeant is shocked because he was
told that Joseph will be eliminated in
the facility Anna then reveals that the
red blinking device is a reprogramming
tool used by the cisa to control
enhanced people turning them into
involuntary weapons this Revelation
finally convinces George that he has
been deceived by his organization and he
now decides to help Anna in the the next
scene they get on to snowmobiles and
make it to the main road there they're
approached by the same stranger who
again offers to help Anna the guy is
reluctant to trust George but Anna
manages to convince him that he's on
their side he then drives the two of
them to his secret house where they meet
another enhanced guy Lou The Stranger
also introduces himself as Eli who used
to work for cesa as an analyst however
he didn't know that the organization was
actually experimenting on people and he
found out only when the facil got
attacked by David as they Converse Eli
unveils cea's attempt to create a super
serum and access another dimension with
Infinite Energy however to harness this
energy they needed to reach its source
that is none other than David here it's
revealed that David is not an actual
human but an interdimensional being who
doesn't age nor does he die when cisa
absorbed his energy to inject it into
humans David lost his ability to return
back to his Dimension since since then
he has been tracking down all the
enhanced humans and reabsorbing his
energy killing them in the process once
he regains his full power he can open
the portal to return home according to
Eli the only way to kill David is to
weaken him to the point that he won't be
able to regenerate himself and then
deliver a final blow armed with this
knowledge George decides to return to
the headquarters and assemble his team
along with some Advanced weapons to
eliminate the threat but before he can
leave David shows up at the door and
kills Eli Lou then instructs George and
Dana to run away while he decides to
stay behind and fight David after a few
minutes of fierce fight David overpowers
Lou and absorbs his energy meanwhile
George and Anna are trying to escape in
a car but David catches them in the neck
of time he throws Anna away and drops a
large container on her following this he
proceeds to absorb her energy but George
stops him he forwards a deal he'll take
David to the place where all the
captured and enhanced people are kept
but only if he spares Anna David accepts
the deal and the two drive towards the
secret government facility Anna who is
still under the container musters up all
of her power to get out of it on the way
George asks David about his motive to
which the latter responds that he needs
to go back to his Dimension furthermore
he expresses his disdain for the current
Dimension and he pies humans for living
in this kind of hellish place while
David is talking George slowly grabs a
taser from the vehicle and pushes him
out of the car before driving away the
sergeant then arrives at the
headquarters to warn the team about the
imminent threat however he has stopped
at the entrance and cuffed before
talking to Captain Williams he tells the
captain about David's intention and how
they should work together to neutralize
the threat regardless Captain Williams
is aware that he has been helping the
enhanced people which is against their
protocol so he does not believe in him
the captain also Reveals His multiple
reprogrammed enhanced people whom he
intends to use as a weapon to confront
David George tries to explain that David
will absorb all the energy from them
which will only make him stronger
however the undeterred captain doesn't
listen to him and locks him in a Cell
all of a sudden an alarm goes off and
the security cam reveals David who is
incapacitating all the guards at the
entrance Door Williams then dispatches
three of his enhanced humans after him
but they are no match for the formidable
David after subduing everyone in his
path he makes it to Williams and kills
him instantly he then turns to George
and tells him that Anna will suffer
because of him just then Anna shows up
and challenges him to try making her
suffer the two of them get into an
intense fight while George continues his
attempts to break out of the cell David
who has become much stronger now is able
to defend all of her attacks and starts
beating her up badly eventually he
knocks her down and proceeds for a final
strike but just then officer Scott
appears from behind and shoots him with
a rifle Furious David turns around and
delivers a powerful blow ripping his
insides out at the same time George
frees himself and launches his attack on
the villain but he soon gets overpowered
David then proceeds to finish him off B
Anna attacks him from behind resuming
their fierce battle in the meantime the
injured George grabs the captain's
device and uses it to unlock all the
cell doors he then crawls his way
towards a button and triggers it to
release a gas that slowly disables all
superpowers now with no power left David
weakens and starts feeling pain in the
body and it takes this opportunity to
beat him up eventually knocking him down
to the floor she picks up a gun to
finish him off once and for all in his
debilitated State David pleads for Mercy
imploring Anna not to kill him when she
hesitates George takes the firearm from
her and guns him down without any second
thought the scene then cuts to 4 months
later and we see Anna living a simple
life as a mechanic one day she meets
George Who hands her the details of all
the enhanced humans urging her to help
them get a normal life as well in the
final scene we see another enhanced
young man going through his daily
routine as he gets ready for work he
hears a ring at the door and goes to
answer it's none other than David who
says that he has come to take something
that belongs to
him subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching